so right over here we have the graph of
y is equal to x squared or at least part
of the graph of y is equal to x squared
and the first thing I'd like to tackle
is think about the average rate of
change of Y with respect to x over the
interval from X equaling 1 to X equaling
3 so let me write that down we want to
know the average rate of change of Y
with respect to x over the interval from
X going from 1 to 3 that's a closed
interval where X could be 1 and X could
be equal to 3 well we could do this even
without looking at the graph if I were
to just make a table here where if this
is X and this is y is equal to x squared
when X is equal to 1 Y is equal to 1
squared which is just 1 you see that
right over there and when X is equal to
3 y is equal to 3 squared which is equal
to 9 and so you can see when X is equal
to 3 y is equal to 9 and to figure out
the average rate of change of Y with
respect to X you say okay well what's my
change in X well we can see very clearly
that our change in X over this interval
is equal to positive 2 well what's our
change in Y over the same interval our
change in Y is equal to when X went
increased by 2 from 1 to 3 y increases
by 8 so it's going to be a positive 8 so
what is our average rate of change well
it's going to be our change in Y over
our change in X which is equal to 8 over
2 which is equal to 4 so that would be
our average rate of change over that
interval on average every time x
increases by 1 Y is increasing by 4 and
how did we calculate that we looked at
our change in X let me draw that here we
looked at our change in X and we looked
at our change in Y which would be this
right over here and we calculated chain
and why over change of X for average
rate of change now this might be looking
fairly familiar to you because you're
used to thinking about change in Y over
change in X as the slope of a line
connecting two points and that's indeed
what we did calculate if you were to
draw a secant line between these two
points we essentially just calculated
the slope of that secant line and so the
average rate of change between two
points that is the same thing as the
slope of the secant line and by looking
at the secant line and compares into the
curve over that interval it hopefully
gives you a visual intuition for what
even average rate of change means
because in the beginning part of the
interval you see that the secant line is
actually increasing at a faster rate but
then as we get closer to 3 it looks like
our yellow curve is increasing at a
faster rate than the secant line and
then they eventually catch up and so
that's why the slope of the secant line
is the average rate of change is it the
exact rate of change at every point
absolutely not
the curves rate of change is constantly
changing it's at a slower rate of change
at the beginning part of this interval
and then it's actually increasing at a
higher rate as we get closer and closer
to 3 so over the interval there change
in Y over the change in X is exactly the
same now one question you might be
wondering is why are you learning this
in a calculus class couldn't you have
learned this in an algebra class the
answer is yes but what's going to be
interesting is really one of the
foundational ideas of calculus is well
what happens as these points get closer
and closer together we found the average
rate of change between 1 & 3 or the
slope of the secant line from 1 comma 1
to 3 comma 9 but what instead if you
found the slope of the secant line
between 2 comma 4 and 3 comma 9 so what
if you found this slope but what if you
wanted to get even closer let's say you
wanted to find the slope of the secant
line between the point two point five
six point two five and three comma nine
and what if you just kept getting
closer and closer and closer well then
the slopes of these secant lines are
going to get closer and closer to the
slope of the tangent line at x equals
three and if we can figure out the slope
of the tangent line well then we're in
business because then we're not talking
about average rate of change we're going
to be talking about instantaneous rate
of change which is one of the central
ideas that is the derivative and we're
going to get there soon but it's really
important to appreciate that average
rate of change between two points is the
same thing as the slope of the secant
line and as those points get closer and
closer together and as the the secant
line is connecting to closer and closer
points together as they that distance
between the points between the X values
of the points approach zero very
interesting things are going to happen